the inside of the heart is one of the
most harsh environments inside the body
it's extremely dynamic constantly
expanding and contracting let's say to
hurricane of blood inside the heart of
all the places you can perform an
operation the Hutt's probably one of the
hardest it's even harder when that heart
is very small like in the chest of an
infant 10,000 of which require
open-heart surgery every year if you
want to repair a heart defect physically
you need to open the chest of the baby
expose the hearts to suture the defect
that can cause a lot of damage to this
issue we really compelled to try to do
something to solve this problem and so
we went off and developed this adhesive
that could work in the harshest
environment in the body inside a beating
heart in 2009 a team at MIT was asked to
solve a problem how can you repair a
hole in the heart of a child without
using stitches or staples you're setting
out to create a new kind of adhesive
what were you looking to create what
were some of the properties of that
adhesive that you needed it to have a
lot of materials can react with blood
and therefore would not be able to
attach to the tissue the material that
we've developed is hydrophobic and what
that means it can actually repel water
repel blood so we can place this inside
of beating heart and then what happens
is that it will actually start to
infiltrate into the tissue it's almost
like a tissue velcro so it just walks
into the tissue and then the hearts
actually expanding and contracting you
know on the order of 60 times a minute
and so you know the materials have to be
able to respond to that why don't you
tell me a little bit about what this
here contraption is going to do so this
is a mechanical tester we can grab the
tissue and the patch we just cured with
the glue
and measure the DC force that the glue
can generate you're actually gonna be
able to get a reading of the the level
of adhesion as it were yes exactly we
see that our DS if games to sign around
two kilograms of force per square
centimeter and that's strong enough to
remain in the heart septum you can see
that the top of the tissue is bent up
geckos blue needs to be strong but it
also needs to know when to get out of
the way and that's what makes it
particularly impressive the glue can
work with the patient's own body to help
create an even better permanent fix what
happens is that as the material degrades
the patient's own tissue forms a bridge
and that seals the hole and eventually
the material is completely gone and the
patient has their own tissue that's
ceiling the whole so besides working
within the heart there are other places
where this technology could go can you
tell me a little bit about that in terms
of other cleaning applications there's
many things that we can think about and
that we are currently exploring for
example when delaney she needs to bring
two vessels together we can apply our
glue to seal the leak we can also think
about other approaches present Paula
notes are in the stomach we can use our
our adhesive it really facilitates how
the surgeon can work and can leave him a
lot of control over the surgical
procedure we formed the company gecko
biomedical to translate this technology
and we are determined to try to get this
to patients as soon as we can it's
actually scheduled to be first in man
testing later this year geckos hope is
that widespread use of their product
besides making the company a lot of
money will lead to fewer invasive open
surgeries cutting down on recovery time
for patients and reducing the risk of
infections
the dream of every person that the
science is always to translate something
to the clinics and I think the most
exciting moment was when we were able to
show that we could stick these patches
inside a beating heart in a live animal
of course it was the moment where we
knew that we had something that could
really impact the quality of life of
patients